the last thing i have not mentioned  is the battle "me"  aka the youtube king vs t-series
My final move i have revealed all my strengths so far
ExTrEmELy HaNDsoME anD GOoD lOokING
VERY big tongue. I can eat G-fuel rAw
Crab king
But number 5
Listen to this
I am, INCREDIBLY SMARTTT *ANIME WOW*
hundred and forty IQ
TKS TKS TKS (idk anymore)
200 IQ? Ay don't make me laugh HA
five thousand IQ is that all you have?
my IQ has been measured
to 100...
1.000.000...
100. (well that's a lot to share pewd)
so don't even try to compete with me
because i'm just too smart
tHanK yOu
thank you.
now
of course, we're going to review
i am very smart
of coUurSe
because you're very smart and you knew this was coming
let's review and look at other very smart people
to intimidate t-series
on earth:
a magiciam (lol)
put his hand -on his- in his hat
in the rabbit realm:
the hand emerges. it is time. the rabbit council must choose a sacrifice.
actually that's not what's happening
"magicians" use the techniques such as misdirection
and prestidiJIgitation
to pull of these illusions.
yes i know
i am a nerdy
emmnghh (͠≖ ͜ʖ͠≖)
[pewd's laughing]
this has to be sarcastic
i know magic isn't real imma quite a nerd
not everyone will get this
this is a really tricky meme, that is not everyone will get
*gasps* eWey aRe tHosE aLcoHol molecules????
and is that why?
oh yeah i forgot
you're studying art. how could you possibly know basic level?
dude. everyone knows what h2o is
we were in the same biology contest last year
and you got 4th place (loooollll)
then you got butt hurt and stormed off crying
I AM VERY sMaRT
*high-pitched voice* (family-friendly-word) you. i got higher grades in bio and math than u
or did u forget?
oh no, i remember (x2), walking to the classroom
during the lunch break and hearing and seeing u begging
to the teacher
for the grade, becuz u need it for college
*high-pitched voice* eat shit and
DIEEEEE
demn.
someone hurt this man
nOt evRiOne WilL gEt ThIs
he just want to share a meme
anyone who doesn't like big bang
is just too stupid to get the jokes
get it?
BANG
[laughing like an absolute madman]
oh he posted this
and it just pathetic
this song has somewhat of a 90s vibe
[OH NO NO humming version]
that's actually a common misconception
the paradigm inheret to the postmodernist fallacy
of a priori knowledge stems from a systemic predilection
to binary
diketomoise (very well prouce pewd)
imagine anyone being like this in real life
EHEHE
you know they spent a lot of time
writing this down, making sure -
"OKAY lets now add predilection to the binary -
-diktomenies" (again, well prouce pewd)
(ooph, about time for him to finally realize)
DICHOTOMIES (finally)
what the fudge is that
this pictures were taken just 2 years apart
hashtag STOP VEGANNS
vegans are eating all our grass
we need them to STOP
we need to STOP themm
it's called going to a different biome
its called a jOKE. LMAO
oof. got them
okay. yeah. i know
but i tend to be too logical for my own good
i am so smart
that i'm just too logical
so when i am WRONG,
i am actually not WRONG
i am toO LOGICAL
you can't compete with this
*grunts* PWERRR [incoherent word]
instead of saying motherfricker
you can just say
Oedipus
[pewd's cute laughing]
half our generation wouldn't even understand
[another cute laughing] (can't get enuf of em)
yes youre right. the thousands of *nom* notes
on this post prove how ignorant our generation is
*inhale*
only youre intelligent
you are the chosen one
only real Ancient Greek kids would understand
reblog if youre a true
650BC kid
uWu
ancient greek was 2 thousand
6 hundred years ago?
this is embarassing
you thought it was 650BC? what an idio-
oh shed.
[strange noises]
SHUT UP.
im very smart
okEHEH
*grunt* I AM eheh I AM JUST TOO LOGICAL FOR MY OWN GOOD
[panting]
MoViNg On
my bed, me in the morning
"Cats are actually--"
you know when they use a word "actually", you know
you're -got- about to got hit by the
fattest smart balm (???) is i like to call it
aCtuAllY
"--crepuscular, which means they are also quite nocturnal animal
using a cat to represent this is not very effective
*gibberish talk*."
that's all i hear from you
you dumbballs. okay?
how about this:
NO ONE GIVE A SHIT
im on the side of the idiots now
not that im proving myself
S T F U
im smarter than u
how?
mathematics sUrRouNdS me
i see numbers everywhere
what the fudge d'ya said even supposed to mean?
is ur dict 3.14 inches long?
DEEEEYYYMMMMMM
you just got -eskmf- MATH
i only musturbeyt mentally (wut????)
my thoughts are so intricate that they can make me hum and i luv that
i dont believe in physical mesturbeytion
my mind makes me cuym
wutda heg
dont make me think it
OoOoOopSie
NAH
he's trying to hold his brains in as his mind get blown
to be fair
those are all fairly trivial equations
although im sure impressive at the time
explain them
[chuckles]
hmm ( ͠° ͟ʖ ͡°)
too blurryhiHIHIHE
hMmmmM i guess i cannot actually see them
this is how you know someone is truly smart
because when confronted with their statements
they contradict themselves entirely
which is the best way, to prove your point
this is also cringe
Everyone else at 10:30: "I guess I'll watch po**"             Me at 10:30: *sees video about hyperbolic functions* "Wait what? That's a thing? Damn it, now i have to watch it.
hashtag
*whipers* math is my curse (oOOoOo)
math, is my curse
if math is your curse, then smash like and subscribe to this video
only a tru math lords will understand
i asked my cousins if he liked the book i lent him
what a great way, not at all condiscending to speak to someone
after wriYHAHAHAHAHA
ooh that's so great
how is this real?
it's annoying when people write
ins- eh whatever. idk how to say that
(PICTURE)
quasi-literate fudge head, is a great diss
if anyone (???) to you, there is no recovery
that's how you know youre not just very sMaRt, but very sUpeR SmArt
"we have 2 wifi channels, --
one is 2.4ghz
and one is 5ghz
i really want to name them "who are you" and "im you but stronger"."
"technically
if you did so,
it would be correct.
the 5 ghz channel is able to support more devices on its channel due to it having a higher bandwith.
that and its a more modern implementation into --
raowters."
(read it urself egen)
just in case you randomly made a joke
and didnt understand ur own punchline
youre welcome, i am very sMarT
ABOGABOGABOB
UNUSUAL
you know, you know someone just couldnt handle this
considering ive never met a whamen, smarter than me
hhmMMnmn ( ͠° ͟ʖ ͡°)
well thats a bit unfair, considering ive never met a mehn, smarter than me either
ooOOOH GAAAWD
jesus christ
how did this people exist? and why there's so many of them
its BEAUTIFUL. (must agree pal)
here we go
EHE
hey Elon Musk, it's: had to BE done, not: had to been done
it's youre welcome, not: ur welcome. write correct english please.
#BeCautiousWithYourTweets
jesus fudging christ
we're gon have to end that video there. hope you guys enjoy it, smash like and subscribe
if youre very smart. (#SmartPeopleOnly)
just so i can know if you guys are very smart
it is not a ploy to get more likes and subscribers on this video
youre too smart to understand that anyway.
brofist?
NAH